Like a boss
[inaudible]
you know, it's like the next
thing that was coming up was, uh,
somebody up there likes me, which I'd
always heard of when I was growing up.
And then once I saw it was Paul
Newman, I was like, all right,
I'm going to watch it.
And it was him playing out rocky
Graziano the rocky Graziano story.
Oh boy. They just try to
fool you got to lousy Coptic.
I'm gonna land my [inaudible], but I
don't leave me alone. Leave me alone.
Why don't you give up on me? My
[inaudible] will be everybody else
knows. Why don't you give up on me?
And, um, and I literally forget what
I was talking. Oh, that's right.
That's right. So it just got me on
this, this, this Paul Newman thing.
And you know what's funny is,
uh, this, this thing, actually,
Steve McQueen is in that
movie for fucking two seconds.
Okay. What do you say? Fight out?
Come on. Get on. Huh?
And uh, it's right as, uh, Graziani
was getting out of some fucking, uh,
you know, juvenile detention
home that he fucking escapes.
So He's going around the
neighborhood, tapping all these guys,
all this tough guy,
friends on the shoulders.
Hey Shorty degree, come on
buddy boy, we got work to do.
[inaudible]
to be like, Hey I'm back
in the neighborhood.
And all of them turn around like
who the fuck is this guy? Right?
Cause cause it Tufts street
kids so fucking a fucking
Steve McQueen is shooting
pool.
The rocky taps him on the shoulder and
he fucking turns around with a knife out
just two seconds and then he
realizes it's reads like it's rocky.
He's like, hey rocky.
And he does this stupid fucking thing
with his hand that I don't know who
fucking,
there's certain things in movies that
the first guy who plays that guy does and
then it's this weird fucking thing
where every other actor after it starts
fucking doing it and you
know, nobody ever did it.
Who's actually the guy
that they're playing.
But then it's done enough in fucking
movies that the people who are actually
that guy, then they start fucking doing
it. And that's when it becomes a circle.
And you don't know who the fuck it
is. It's this fucking thing like, uh,
it's almost like,
say you were getting a mannequin right
and you wanted to dry off your nails and
you do just see exec a rocky and he's
doing this stupid fucking thing with his
hand. Um, I dunno,
I'm going a really long way here to
tell you what I really want to tell you.
But like one of my favorite things is
to watch actors during that era playing
Tufts street kids. Um, like it's just,
it's fucking cringeworthy that fucking
movie that Marlon Brando did. Oh,
he's on the motorcycle. What
the fuck was that one called?
It's not the wild bunch. That was a
cowboy movie. Rebel without a cot.
Now that's James Dean. I
can't remember, but just the,
the have to sit there
and watch that shit. Um,
how fucking brutal it
is that west side story,
which I don't think I've ever seen.
I'm just gonna throw that in there
cause I need three of them. Um,
[inaudible]
how can you ask me to go on a courthouse
building that happens to be what people
get married? Well, being in courthouse
just makes me be uncomfortable.
Stuff on the please. [inaudible]
just tell me you don't love
[inaudible].